[Music]
alright so in that cop news submitted by
a Jordan Craig a pregnant Khloe
Kardashian is a shock after video
evidence is released of her boyfriend
apparently cheating that is so sad oh
yeah oh that's the one that was with
Lamar Odom yeah so she went from a
basketball player to another basketball
player yes is Khloe this is Tristan Tom
Thomson yeah and she's about to give
birth any minute and so just recently
though it came out that this dude was
cheating on her over the weekend with
some ID model oh no a basketball player
that cheats I've never heard that's
exactly what I'm thinking yeah a lot of
people are like well celebrities
cheating is kind of like a prerequisite
right
it's not fair to just be like well duh
you should know better
no no not that I'm just kind of like the
new what's diff like you're a celebrity
you cheap a word on the street is his
last baby mama when she was pregnant he
cheated with her oh that's like his
fetish oh yeah and he left he left the
the pregnant baby mama and then sorry
David miss girl what if she is pregnant
and I know he's just jumping on
something that's like his fetish he
likes to cheat on a girl literally two
weeks before the baby's due that's like
his [ __ ] it turns him on girl he was
cheating on apparently like she's
pregnant by you just have sex and like
[ __ ] don't come in there rapid it's
hard probably probably just has a lot of
pre-cum it's hard to resist it smiley
Cullotta pre-cum you're right doesn't he
wanna just keep his [ __ ] money though
like why but in the moment of about when
you're about to bust you're not thinking
about your bank account yeah sure that's
true you should have like jacked off a
few times before depleted all that semen
and then
that's so funny he can't wait yeah man
like wait during the but like being
pregnant and like just seeing how that
kind of affected our sex life like okay
I get it like you're horny or whatever
but then have a conversation with your
lady breaking news
Khloe Kardashian give birth right now
congratulations he's like ballin - he
could get like some really expensive
escorts if he just wants to bust a nut
well here's the thing professional side
chicks do one hell of a job and what
it's like that's all they do is figure
how do I finesse this yeah you feel like
it's not about the money they make you
feel special when the whole time they
got a game plan you know what would be
interesting to me is when I see like a
breaking news this celebrity couple have
been in love and together loyally the
whole time years they're you know it's
been great like that would be news to me
yeah but the cheating I feel like is
like duh isn't that like 99% of [ __ ]
Hollywood yeah I know they need to
change up their pure game huh cuz now
it's just like it's like wow another
another scandal needs to not be news
period like what he did was shitty
if they don't have an open relationship
agreement we don't know that but yeah
why the [ __ ] do they have to report it
they know she's the brasses really cares
about it but why would you do that to
her who cares about her like she pricks
she's about to give birth to you like oh
let's put this video up you kidding wait
you could wait til I would still be
shocking we're talking about it like
that's how huge it is I know the money
maker the people who put it leave it
couldn't have waited but we all know an
entertainment it's it's a heartless game
yeah yeah
it's like this is the perfect moment
because it's so scandalous yeah yeah
yeah I really want to see a couple
that's like an arm B singer and a rapper
that stayed together and didn't cheat on
each other because even [ __ ] jay-z
and beyonce that [ __ ]
yeah and her album was about how big of
a piece of [ __ ] he was yeah
I'm gonna show you guys a clip there's a
compilation of all these video clips
that came out with him cheating on Chloe
so this first one apparently was when
Chloe was three months pregnant and he's
making out with these two girls well he
motorboats one he makes out with the
other hard for celebrities to stay chill
so didn't none of these girls are the
ones that we're talking about where he
cheated on her over this past weekend
damn she was like she knows what she
doing actually really like it's
purposeful apparently this girl right
here the one that he was making out with
she was present when when Chris Brown
made headlines recently where he was
like playfully choking some chick that
was her it was she was the one being
choked for she was in though she's in
the group oh damn so she looks like Kim
Kardashian's that just took place see
you studies I know he's prepping for a
movie role
so he's motorboating her and then it
leads to like him
I guess telling him I like dude I got a
hard-on and then they start feeling what
what where is this at at a club we did a
good job got him hard he could have been
there taken advantage of him
[Music]
and then people are like where's Chloe
where it's not even what you are the
crazy thing is is that in public photos
that is the camera that's a great camera
though this is a G model the IG model /
works at a strip club yeah she's a
bartender at a strip club and that's
apparently how they met look at these
pictures I go I don't know how you smell
so I can't make any judgments cuz he
might be hot as [ __ ] but I don't I might
not like their smell yeah she look like
she's you better smell good she look
like she smelled like cocoa butter and
citrus she probably does so then shortly
before all this surface like all this
cheating should happen Chloe you posted
this before it happened before before
everything like it surfaced it was like
I think the day before something I love
big black men that play basketball
Jenner captioning we are ready whenever
you are little mama uh was she talking
to little baby
oh no cuz they had a baby girl
that's so sad apparently those sources
are saying that people close to Chloe
kept warning her and like the family too
like don't get too serious with this
dude like look what he just did to the
last baby mama and she was like I don't
want to hear it he's the one you know
what is I mean he literally does it in
public
at a club that's kind of her bad because
people been telling her that and on top
of that she knows that he left a girl
while she was pregnant now yeah but he's
not read I changed them you don't mean
like I see I'm like if she could do that
to him
but you know what do that to me yeah I
mean like the big difference is is that
girl wasn't me all right and I've heard
that so many times
illusional that's as stupid as a guy
going to a strip club and in saying she
thinks I'm special yeah like she told me
I'm special because I'm different yeah
I'm not like the old guys here exactly I
mean like the [ __ ] dude she's a stripper
I mean the whole thing can be fake with
the Kardashian family like it could just
been a setup from the beginning yeah and
I mean a lot of celebrity couples they
have agreements they know what the [ __ ]
is going on they just act away and when
people get caught doing the [ __ ] because
they have to yeah yeah you can't be long
oh no that's cool bring a baby and see
how you gonna bring a [ __ ] life into
such progr her brother did it I think
it's like if it was something like
because it's all fake and then all the
stress made her lose a baby or whatever
then I'm like okay fine like that's
[ __ ] up and spineless but I just don't
bring up a human it's like this like
they're together right and they got that
[ __ ] agreement but she's probably
pissed off that he did it in public and
he got caught he's stupid with it no
that's that's always waited yeah yeah
the [ __ ] did you do that [ __ ] in public
you dumbass maybe she wanted that so
that she gets sympathy and people buy
into her grand more
yeah because when you showed up to the
first basketball game it was a Cavs
versus Nick that boot off immediately
when he came out like he got booed like
that now announce when he got the badge
and he did like the worst thing ever
though like did that with the chick
being pregnant with his baby yeah no I'm
not saying that I'm not sympathizing for
him it's like there's crazy hot but what
the aftermath is yeah I think that's
just like the big celebrities reaching
out to him saying like man I'm so sorry
you're going through this but you know
do you think that's orchestrated though
like Kardashian style maybe cuz there
are they are [ __ ] genius when it
comes to marketing and staying in and
public eye and all that [ __ ] they are
like they have no soul like they'll do
whatever the [ __ ] it takes like damn I
wish I was that more or less I think I
would be more successful if I if I was
just man anything like me bar should
just [ __ ] get into a huge fight and
then like so much drama and Jacob if I
can make some [ __ ] up I don't think any
more
here the word hey well I think we could
that's how you build fan bases though I
mean a lot we know a lot of youtubers
that do that I hate that [ __ ] but I
still click when it's like someone so I
don't even know little [ __ ] they get
into a fight right yeah and then I'm
gonna try to break it up and somehow you
both punch me at the same time and I die
but that wouldn't be a surprise I think
if you punched them and you knock them
out then that would be better it's not
about the surprise is about the shock of
me dying no I think it's expected that
your I'll come back a year later
surprise yeah that's right evil twin
I'll be I will be me somehow they'll
give me a brain transfer i'ma
transferred to your body okay that's
just weird
no and then Bart's gonna try to kiss you
whenever like it's repart boom punch him
in the face
new story even harder I don't care about
being gay guess what part I'm Gia
well let's see how tough you are see if
you really about that like brother
[Music]